our steve sisselat giving some positive
news on the vaccine front while also
sending the message there is more work
to be done encouraging anyone who hasn't
yet to get the vaccine sasha loftus
joins us live outside of the grant
sawyer office building now with more
sasha
ryan the get out the vaccine movement
has come to a close but according to
governor sislak it was extremely
successful here in clark county and all
across the state
state data shows 63 percent of nevadans
12 and over have initiated vaccination
while 53 percent are fully immunized
governor sisilek says clark county has
one of the top three vaccination rates
he spoke on how fema teams helped part
of north las vegas bump vaccine rates by
22 percent but the governor says there's
still more work to do please help
protect yourselves your family your
community and our economy
by getting vaccinated against 19.
it's a simple shot
that can help keep us protected and keep
our economy open zip codes were chosen
for canvassing and education based on
social vulnerability and low vaccination
rates
governor siselek did speak on masked
mandates here in clark county as well he
said that any county in nevada has to
hit 8 percent positivity rate or lower
for multiple weeks in order for those
mass to come off and clark county has
not yet met that threshold reporting
live in las vegas tonight sasha loftis
live local now